I work in the Franklin programming lab
here in the scrotum science we're
interested in finding program languages
and techniques for making it easy to
divide beta programs and we believe
they're not functional programming is a
way to achieve that functions are quite
simple and very well specified loving it
easy to put big system together using
small small reusable functions but only
question is ok we took a function to
mathematical sense and it's easy to
understand how you might apply the
function to say compute the square of to
some something like that um but can we
also use it to write say interactive
applications or games or musical
applications that's not so clear that we
have an application here it's called the
arpeggio and it's patterned after or
something called the react Lagaan which
is say so-called chain reactive
performance arpeggiator and this was
implemented using a functional
programming and then more specifically a
variation of functional programming
called reactive functional programming
that is tailored for doing these kind of
interactive applications ok so now
that's one way in which become do write
games or animations or or music
applications in a functional language
I'm like in the sounds do we need all
this equipment to make this work
no it's all sort of MIDI based so we can
just make connected to a sofa
synthesizer for example and then
everything can be contained in the
laptop but because it is media base you
can also use as a component of a largest
studio set up for example now I've seen
applications like this sort of thing in
in the music world before so what's new
here I suppose why would somebody
consider going down this route well the
thing is that time is of course central
to music right and you need two kinds of
time we have both continuous-time and
discrete-time so a musical note my
started a very positive point in time
but if you have say a crescendo or
natural Rundle or something takes place
over a period of time in gradually
changing I'm inviting application like
this for music is a nice to have a
language
we can express aspects about time in a
way that really fits the application
domain and frankly not the programming
support is kind of what we call hybrid
systems both continuous and discrete
time aspects okay in a very high-level
way so it makes it easier to write these
kind of applications so the arpeggio gun
is based on something called the
harmonic table and the monic table is
this kind of hexagonal grid musical
notes are placed on this grid in this
direction have a specific musical
intervals if you could North it's a
perfect fifth if you go north east it's
a major third and so on and so forth
just so people if they're not that
musical understand the idea of this is
that harmonics and things mean that
it'll sound musical it won't just yes so
for example if you play a note and the
perfect fifth and a major third you get
a major chord which sort of sounds nice
together right it's very easy to play
sounds together sounds nice if you have
this kind of layout
can you show so that'd be like on a
keyboard I mean here well a major chord
on the keyboard would be something like
this right
what's mostly interesting here there is
that we have this two dimensional layout
so we can use that to sort of example
implement a kind of pinball game if you
like so you can place these tokens or
counters on the grid and if you have a
few different ones here
meaning cycle different things so that
thing there with the dot that's a start
token so maybe best play is going to put
the ball on the grid and shoot it off in
the direction in academic arrow and the
other one there is a ricochet token and
whenever the ball hits it is going to
sort of bounce back in the directional
of the arrow and whenever the ball hit a
token which we're going to play the
corresponding note if I start this you
will see this ball is bouncing back and
forth and we get a kind of musical
pattern there right and we can even if
you want to can even modify the layouts
dynamically we could imagine performing
with this if you wanted to we could put
more start counters onto the grid now
with the different distance between them
and that means that I may hit play here
we're going to get more of a
polyrhythmic pattern I gotten two
different patterns of different lengths
playing at the same time so they go out
so say yes and learning in sync again
right and we can continue playing this
game I can place a few more or these
ones up here and the last one there and
then we press play
it's quite nice I think at least it's a
new musical taste I suppose but I like
it these all guaranteed because of this
pattern in this layout to be musical you
couldn't make a cacophony I guess
musical depends on the the listener
right but it certainly makes it look
easy to make a musical because you have
this specific intervals absolutely yes
and complete could people play with this
themselves as yes this is free software
is available online you can download it
and play with it right now it's a bit
rough around the edges but we're working
on to make it more polished and easy to
use
why is it only you mentioned time let's
try and clarify that then why is it
easier to write something like this in
your functional reactive programming
rather than say Java all right so the
thing is that in fine-tuned writing
program or FRP as we say we have a
number of language constructs that deals
with time directly and both in
continuous time and discrete time so if
you had these elements at your disposal
you can express in this case musical
ideas much more directly than you
couldn't say Java or or C obviously
depending on on the specific context
sometimes you might want to write a
piece of C code or whatever and
obviously if you work hard enough in C
you can implement this kind of of them
support in C as well right but here we
have done it for you in in a sense and
in a very principled way which makes it
people in the faculty problem in context
can you see other applications for this
not like chime critical things have been
used for games for example and the ideas
of reactive programming is seeing
increased use for banking applications
think whenever you have a distributed
system and they sort of communicate you
can view these communications as signals
over time and then you can sort of
process them using F or P like ideas yes
quite big take up now if a P is not just
one system a lot of different systems as
it's more than umbrella term and
depending on exactly what you do there
are different implementation of P that's
more or less suitable but ID as such has
really got traction and in particular in
a video setting it's important that
everything is purely functional because
if things are not purely functional then
becomes very difficult to handle the
side effects but if everything is pure
than every node in this systems has a
function and they communicate by signals
is a very good fit for complex
distributed systems so is a for PA
language or other languages that
it's a an umbrella term for a number of
related languages let's say what's next
for this is for a project and we would
really want to
to make it into a tool that people can
use for stomp in studio setting that
like this because we think actually this
is the only software implementation of
the reactive gun that we are aware of
and if people like to compose music in
this particular way we think it could be
quite nice application ignoring how it's
written just for an end user to use what
do you mention this react where it's
gone I mean what is that what how does
that look normally is that a piece of
hardware that was a piece of hardware so
you can you can google react one on
YouTube will find on YouTube and you
will see this big impressive table with
lots of hardware on it and you can least
count of physical things you can place
on the board and interact with it that's
very cool
but this is easier to use obviously and
cheaper right we've done B we can count
that as done so C next right so we're
here
we can't go to s we can only go to L
that's a nice easy one so I need to find
out so L goes to C and it's three plus
two is five so L comes in just
underneath a like this